when you go to Starbucks to get your
latte you ask for a large iced latte
right and then you get the latte first
and then you say oh can I have a cup of
milk I do the same thing and then you
mix it and you have two lattes it won't
be even better you get a regular black
coffee okay they give it to you and then
you say oh by the way can I get a cup of
ice yes pour it over yeah the icing can
I get like a little thing of cream see
that's crazy because you're basically
getting 300 the amount exactly but the
ice takes up oh yeah when they pour the
ice in that yeah you're really only
getting half a drink the other half's
water so just get the normal coffee pour
it over ice which is free